[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet this week that person
is a monk rawson known on the internet
as alpha cat he's one of the most
recognized Barack Obama impersonators in
the Whizzer old
you remember Obama singing Beyonce yeah
single ladies 20 million views that was
him and Ti yes that was him 20 million
views and the epic rap battles of
history against Romney yeah 81 million
views link okay now that's a mod in mine
he's a lot more than that a lot more
videos than just those he's a longtime
youtuber with over half a million
subscribers but he's recently
established himself as a superstar on
vine have you heard a vine 2.4 million
followers on that platform so he gives
us a crash course on what vine is and we
discussed the fascinating differences
between vine and YouTube including the
prevalence of black comedians on vine
which is something that we didn't know
how to ask the question but we did want
to talk about it we're to ask it though
we also discuss how a potentially racist
comment changed the entire trajectory of
his career and what it's like living
under the weighty expectations of being
that guy who does the Obama
impersonation could you do that for us
again again why are you doing anything
else but that now ok that's what we
discuss I don't know if there is a
presidential mandate about what I have
done as a parent I could definitely see
the first lady saying that she would not
advise me to do this you know the first
lady always has like these mandates and
stuff not really mandates but you know
we're like you know Michelle Obama I
know that if you talk about your wife I
can assume that she has lots of mandates
who know I don't call my wife the first
lady because that would make me some
sort of official and I don't want that
kind of pressure I'm just saying you
know how much you haven't earned it
Michelle Obama wants all the kids to be
in shape but she'll also like do some
stuff for like safety and that kind of
thing
I'm just trying to basically make a
segue into the fact that I've got a
trampoline for my kids and I feel guilty
about it about this and not only do you
have a trampoline you got a used
trampoline right that will the best kind
first of all trampolines are not that
expensive just a few hundred bucks you
can have a very large piece of equipment
in your backyard how much did you pay
for yours zero now this is the same
friend who gave you the NBA Tickets we
talked about this guy
listen you missed the I've known this
guy Jay for like six months sugar that
he's given me more stuff than you've
given me in a lifetime well he's got
connections I don't have it he it's a
reflection of how much I care I don't
care about you read its I only have what
you have because we we're in the same
place in life but I will say that giving
somebody a used trampoline I mean this
is not this is not sugar daddy scenario
it could be argued that it's a it's a
kid death wish I mean these things are
dangerous this is
hey I've got a trampoline my kids don't
want it anymore and Jesse has repeatedly
said my wife has said you know sometimes
the kids drive me crazy and they're
really into gymnastics and diving and
they are those kinds of kids that jump
around and flip and that kind of thing
so and they love trampolines their
cousins have one why don't we get the
kids a trampoline it'll give them
something to do now I I have heard this
Russian how many times and I I get it I
totally get it from friends who have
kids that are just they just want their
just active kids you know I mean your
kids block and Shepherd they are they're
active I mean there are times when they
literally are bouncing off the walls and
it's just you have to channel that into
something positive
or I store it will it it could be
unlivable for someone like Jesse or for
Christie being at home with the kids
homeschooling and I mean or no cost they
are constantly it's difficult jumping on
and off of things
and each other you've got to find a way
to wear them out if you can't afford a
swimming pool well what are you gonna do
right so well I got a free trampoline
that's what I actually I did buy their
family ice cream
they gave me a trampoline yeah you know
and this is funny it's one of those
things that this is why this is why it's
good to have a partner in life sometimes
and if I want my wife
at this juncture okay and that is
because we go over there and they
disassemble the trampoline which is a
lot easier than you would think I mean
this thing breaks down into small pieces
that you can get like the trunk of a car
you like pull one coordinate it just
falls apart right no you have to
individually from these things with a
special tool the springs oh yeah it's
pretty I mean you feel like you're about
to lose an eye
but that didn't happen but then we take
it apart we put it in the in the car and
then they're like you guys want to go
get ice cream
you know the equipment's dangerous when
you could lose an eye taking it apart
well yeah but it's it's probably more
dangerous to assemble in and disassemble
than it is to jump on paediatricians
would not tell you that though so we go
to get ice cream
after this you know after the
disassembly and then we're buying the
ice cream for our family and their
family is ordering ice cream to kind of
like free-for-all like multiple people
ordering from multiple places along the
counter and Jesse's like you should pay
for their ice cream they just gave and
so then I turn around like we got this
we got this payment you know this is the
least that we could do for this
trampoline pay you know give you $15 or
so for ice cream but yeah I mean they
weren't expecting that they didn't give
it to me so they would get free ice
cream they didn't want it anymore and we
could use it what if they did though
well they got the ice cream then I mean
no one's complaining and they didn't
until right now unless Jay is listening
they don't know that it wasn't my idea
so you know did you tell him now I'm
buying this ice cream for you and for
your kids but I just want to let you
know that your kids could choke and die
on this ice cream no it's not it may not
happen but pediatricians say that you
could choke and die on this ice cream
well you've done in the same way
traditions don't say that they don't
know because ice cream melts what if
there's a cherry in there or something
what about trampolines but okay so they
actually do now you know I know there's
more responsible parents out there than
me and I did after we had already made
the decision together
I didn't have to go on the internet to
learn that trampolines are dangerous I
know that people don't recommend
trampoline news and that's why my mom
and dad never let us have one huh my
mom's like you could die on a trampoline
my cousin died or so you know there's
always a story somebody died on a
trampoline because it happens
well you die you get you break your neck
I mean it's a freaking platform in the
back yard that kids jump on I mean this
is not safe that's not why we got it we
didn't get it cuz it was safe we got it
because it was fun but they have a
mosquito net around him now all right
well they do all come with nets most of
them come with nets and it's that's
recommended I do think that that helps
it's for but it's only for malaria
but for some reason I made the mistake
of after I put the thing together which
I'm going to tell you about in one
second has something that happened that
was important I did then began looking
at the research and that was when I
found that you know they asked like
10,000 ER doctors what is a top piece of
advice that you would give to parents
out there the top piece of advice from
ER doctors just say no to trampolines
and I'm like oh you know this I got a
one-way ticket to the emergency room in
my backyard now so I'm that's what I'm
dealing with is a little bit of a guilt
complex but I'll tell you the kids are
having a blast it's funny when you said
that one way ticket to the emergency
room I pictured a kid jumping so high
that he landed in an emergency I don't
think but that's not what you meant no
but I will say it was not easy to put
together you have to stretch the net
across and you have to line it up
perfectly because you've got all these
Springs and they have to be you have to
line them up perfectly or else let you
have to do one and then do one right
opposite from it right that's not the
net that's the bouncy nothing that yeah
did the actual trampoline part of it
then I guess that's what you call it the
bouncy part yeah the black part and I
sit there with my friend Antonio and
then Ron and his family come over and
we're doing this thing it took me you
know an hour and a half maybe to get
this thing put together the very last
step it was impossible to get these last
few Springs into place like we're double
teaming this thing I got I got a pair of
pliers Antonio's got the tool and we're
like all up on each other to kind of
pull in on these things and then Olivia
you know little Olivia who's like eight
years old however
she is run Ron's daughter the girl in
spot the difference the girl from the
spot the differences video all of a
sudden she's like why don't you do it
like this
and we look over there and she has put
in with this she put the spring in the
the bar side the outside of the
trampoline first yeah I know the
trampoline side first and then pulled it
to the bar and it was just like went
right in and we're sitting there two two
adult men with a pair of pliers the tool
that they ring did they give you with
the trampoline I mean I thought I was
going to get a hernia trying to get this
thing in place and this little
eight-year-old girl is over there doing
it correctly and we had done every
single spring except the last like two
and I was like you know what Olivia that
just might work and I go and I do it her
way and it was like the last two were
just oh and I was like why didn't you
say something earlier little girl little
girl that was in our spot the
differences video because that's what we
call you now we call our liver now
question did you go out and buy her an
ice cream cone no no no she didn't give
me the trampoline she just gave me a tip
she gave me at least a frickin klonda
and she didn't help a whole lot I fed
her dinner and they were good they were
there for dinner you know the girl a
Klondike bar man anyway if you've got to
assemble the trampoline first of all
pediatricians will tell you you
shouldn't second of all the springs put
them on the black part first and then
pull them out and put them into the
frame like a nutty buddy or like uh what
kind of nutty buddy what you talking
about like or a popsicle or something
you have anything laying around you can
give her my wife baked cookies for okay
she was well taken care of she was well
compensated for her tip speaking of
trampolines and death-defying stunts we
talked to alpha cat remember that oh
yeah yeah yeah so here it is our
conversation with Amon enjoy
[Music]
okay so we obviously know you through
YouTube not only through our
collaboration way back in the day but
just because you're you on YouTube but
now you are also something arguably even
bigger on vine and I am fascinated by
the world of vine so I want to talk
about that 2.4 million followers on vine
mm-hmm
I mean versus you got six hundred
thousand subscribers on your main
YouTube channel right so over the past
year right the vine thing is just blown
up for you yeah yeah yeah so I want to
get into that okay now I mean I have an
icon on my phone that says vine but I
haven't open it I think I added the
application because I I felt like I
should write like like months and months
ago hmm
maybe when it first started and then I
never did it so I'm just kind of hearing
from the sidelines the whole vine thing
right I think you've like me to write
when you got your account and you don't
do it either yeah this we're going
months back and I didn't really
understand
now I understand but I have not gone
back to enter the world because now it's
gotten like oh I get it now when I watch
it but I'm like I don't know if I get I
don't know if I can do it I don't know
if I can commit just explain it in
general before we get into specifically
what you do and how you blew up and what
that means okay well for those that
aren't familiar with vine it's uh it's a
six second video app for your phone take
six second video and basically with me
and then it loops it and loops it it
loops it automatically indefinitely
actually if you let a video play
continuously it will stop itself and
I've never counted how many I'm gonna
guess like maybe thirty times it'll and
after 30 it'll stop oh really but like
I've been like doing something I'll
watch a vine and set my phone down and
like I forget that it's going but I hear
it in the background and it stops so
there is a point what it'll stop but
that's irrelevant but alright that's
different than Instagram video which
does not loop and it's also longer a 15
seconds yeah up to yeah up to 15 seconds
and vine is six
there's no r26 it's always six well I
think it's I think it's between three
and six I think you know I think you can
post as short as three seconds I'm okay
so you something you can edit the end a
little bit right now you want it so yeah
and I do comedic vines of course and
it's a really interesting world to like
find a medium that's six seconds long
and make it something that works that
people actually want to see right but it
also works because we're in a the
microwave age of things have to be so
instant and so fast the people's time
their attention span is a lot shorter
the free time is a lot less so they
would like to be able to look at
something that's really quick and brief
and then they can just move on you know
and it's right there on your phone I
mean it works like Instagram mmm so when
you first heard about vine and decided
to be a part of it I mean my first
reaction was well I think the Instagram
video came out after vine but not long
after it so when I had first heard of
vine
I knew that Instagram video was coming
out at the same time I was like well I'm
kind of doing Instagram at least a
little bit why would I want to do vine
you know who knew that those differences
would create kind of a its own art form
that's I mean much more prolific on vine
in terms of video than just kind of this
added thing on Instagram what were you
thinking at first with vine at first I
just watched it and I just observed
because I you know it had as as
youtubers and as veteran youtubers it's
like you see these things come out and
sometimes some of them have similarities
to what the original YouTube platform
was like when it first came out and with
vine I saw a lot of similarities and
there's like a pressure to know be in
the know on everything exactly and so I
watched knowing what could potentially
happen and I and just a lot of the
things that I was seeing just reminded
me of YouTube and a good friend of mine
who goes by king batch on on vine I
think he's like the number one account
he he started it off and I was kind of
watching him do it I was just kind of
observing what happened because at the
time I was like so strictly YouTube and
I'm like I have YouTube I have Instagram
you know but I was watching him and his
account was boring and I was saying that
people were taking to it and then that's
when Instagram video came out with their
video stuff mm-hmm and then everyone
swore up and down they're like okay well
that's the end of vine right you know
answer my maths videos video and they're
bigger but in some interesting happens
is that everyone kind of flocked to
Instagram for like a day and then they
came right back to vine and the thing
was at that point that I was like okay I
need to start making vines because if
it's a like another Li a day or like
just it's like overnight it kind of
seemed like overnight I would say I was
I do remember that because when it
happened I had that vine account but I
wasn't thinking I was gonna do anything
with it and then when Instagram came out
with it cuz it wasn't right after it was
I don't know the exact timeline but it
was months maybe a year after and then
it was like all these articles came out
said oh the death of no integrated
people like experts are saying this is
gonna happen I remember thinking exactly
the same thing I was like okay well
there goes vine I feel bad for those
guys who started that company and then I
remember seeing Reggie Watts post
something where he said he said I'm
gonna do I'm not gonna do any videos on
Instagram I'm only gonna do those on
vine and I remember thinking there's
something there and it was this it was
the day after the announcement right you
experienced the same thing and you were
watching King batch who has like 5
million mmm followers mm-hmm so he's a
personal friend of yours even at the
time so you were just kind of watching
his yeah like I was watching him and he
was making some really funny stuff
and I was just kind of observing because
it's you know you kind of have to be
picky with your time especially yeah as
a youtuber so I was like kind of just
observing because there's a lot of other
video sites that have come along like he
can like a lot other ones that just
don't stick around right so I was just
kind of observing his see because I was
like if ITIF it sticks around long
enough then I'll get into it because I
want to be a part of it and was he did
he come from YouTube or he has a YouTube
account but he did he I can't say he
particularly came from YouTube he's an
actor that you know he does a lot of
directing and producing as well as you
know acting as well so okay got it but
so yeah I watched it and like he was
getting more successful then I kind of
got the itch like well I want to do it
cuz this looks fun you know so then I
jumped into it and just like YouTube the
process was pretty much the same it's
like you get into it you have your own
thing that you want to do but then you
collab with people you get them to you
know on their on your account you get on
theirs and just you know you spray each
other's videos it's a lot of the same
thing even some of their like early on
YouTube bickering when people first
started getting attention same thing was
happening
drama so I got a for me I felt kind of
privileged to be able to watch it know
one step by step what was gonna happen
before anything even have even before
like vine like vine now allows you to do
a little bit of editing within the app
in the beginning you couldn't do
anything at all and people that were
finding ways to edit we're getting hated
on because everyone else is like that's
not how it's what it was created to be
and it's supposed to be like this and
the new school kids are like it's
supposed to be like that and then watch
them like this reminds me of YouTube
back in the day like you know certain
people wanted to front page and they
wanted to not have corporation this and
I'm thinking the whole time watch vine
it's gonna start getting corporate any
day now it's gonna happen really quick
so what were some of the first specific
vines you did that were ok this is gonna
work for me too
I think one of the first vines that I
had some good ones early on but the
first one that comes to mind was one
that I did where I was dressed as Obama
and this guy yells me Obama sucks
and we did some whip hands so that we
can kind of like you know hide the cut
yeah hide the cut so we did a whip pan
and then when it when it cuts back to me
I'm suddenly I'm standing I'm saying
what did you say it was back to him and
then he's surrounded by Secret Service
and then they snap his neck and I'm like
you better watch your mouth I got those
goons
you know just walk off and you know
people really like that one and the cool
thing about vine for me was that I was
able to not only introduce what I've
been doing with the whole bomber thing
but also do some original ideas and mix
it up a bit you know and I think doing
that and also for a while like I was
posting at least twice a day for like at
least like a good month straight which
which really helped so a lot of
different things can contribute it so
wasn't yeah you would do some Obama but
then you would do just something else
yeah and the thing is I have 200 and
something vines on my account and only a
fraction of that is Obama you know and
like I think my biggest vine actually is
not even in Obama video so what's the
biggest one of my one of my biggest ones
is called where you from ok that's
actually where you from excuse my
language but I'll call it where you're
from and we're familiar with this one
this is when everybody's dancing in the
swish pan to you and you're like Pierrot
wedding yeah yeah yeah and when I
explained that when it's funny vine
advanced like a lot of ideas are hard to
explain when you have you you make sense
up here and explain any people are just
kind of looking at you like
huh and I saw explaining I was like you
know let's just shoot it and I'm gonna I
was like I'm gonna do some some ballet
stuff so just you know and I don't think
the guys knew that I actually was
classically trained and danced so when I
did it the first take I told him to look
shocks and the first take the I'll
actually were shocked and started
laughing I was like they were like we
didn't know you could do that I was like
yeah I told you I'm gonna do some ballet
stuff so you know we had to do it a few
times and um it came out really good so
and that one just really blew up that
night and how do you measure when it
does well because it's not views right I
mean there's no view counts no view
counts but then you pay attention to
your likes and your vines but
particularly for me like and at where I
met it's good to have like stay like
standards in general it's good to like
get a hundred likes a minute when you
post something if you're I would say
like if you're up you know 100,000
followers and up it's good to have like
100 likes a minute and then after that
you want to look at try to getting 200
likes a minute or three so when I tend
to be in the 200 to 300 likes a minute
range that's a really really good vine
but also at the same time the numbers
are changing because the site's getting
more and more flooded so people aren't
always pulling those numbers anymore
you'll have good ideas and you'll get
good like Sandri vines but you don't
always always pull those numbers anymore
so now we had a storm come in when we
shot a Christmas face music video we did
end of the year and I was kind of
picking his brain about vine and one of
the things he told me was he said I'll
know within just a matter of minutes if
it if a vine I've done is gonna work oh
yeah and then he said that he would take
some down even if they weren't working
he would take him down because he wanted
everything on this channel to be hot
right and really take off right I mean
is that do you go that far to really
kind of comb through what's working or
not take things down if it's if it's not
yeah I mean that's exactly what we do we
all do that like you know we'll put
something up and we watch the like count
within like five to 10 minutes and if
it's not doing what we expect what we
should be if it's not performing up to
par we just take it down well it's
interesting because it's a six second
video so it's not like it's not like a
YouTube video it's not like oh did this
music video I don't care if you don't
like it you're gonna watch exactly a
YouTube video you know the
mics aren't that great well I did it and
it's up secure but a six-second video is
very easy to throw away when you when
it's not if it's not it's not doing well
you know you didn't spend tons of money
on a set and you know extras and you
know crew you just shot it yourself with
your friends so there's not it's not
you're not losing much just to delete a
vine also in terms of having or wanting
to have everything when your page be
really good that helps when people come
to your vine account because there's
Brandon goes a lot of branding deals
going on now and they scroll through it
that you don't want to you don't want
them to see a lot of like nonsense
like for instance I never forget me and
badge had a conversation one King badge
yeah and he was explaining why he did it
cuz I was before I did I used to not
delete anything partially because I'm
that good but no but I was talking about
and he was explaining like how does I
asked him I said why is it that because
we were talking about another Viner who
was much bigger than him at the time and
I said why is this person and just post
anything and they're still growing and
but at the same time you you're very
selective and he and I said but you're I
said he post more than you but you're
still growing more than that guy cuz I
was just watching these two and he said
well it's because I don't put up I don't
let any like random fluff just remain on
my vine account like if it's if it's not
hidden if it's not poppin I take it
right back down so that every single
bond you when you scroll through is like
a big vine or like a really like
impressive vine and it just kind of
convinces your effort well cuz it's
amazing even you know right before you
came in and we're you know kind of
looking at your latest finds the way
that you enjoy somebody's profile is oh
I've just watched 15 vines you know in a
couple of minutes so it does have this
it's just a totally different philosophy
haha how have you seen you know what you
knew about YouTube you've kind of
explained some of these differences
already but what are some of the key
differences between something that works
on YouTube and something that works on
vine I think with with YouTube there's a
lot of differences let me start with
vine with vine it's like you got six
seconds you always want to end on a
punch and you want it to be relatable in
the sense it's very similar to YouTube I
think the difference is just a time
frame in the format you know it's like
you know you have six
seconds on YouTube you have you have
longer on vine you don't have as much
time to build a backstory and you know
tell like an elaborate highbrow joke you
know it's it's it's it's really I don't
want to say rushed because it sounds
like the wrong word but you really kind
of have to get to the point and with
YouTube you can sometimes take a little
longer to develop a joke and to like
have that character arch or that
storyline arch or whatever but you can't
do that on vine if something has to be
like one punch line it's like a one hit
joke yeah really I don't I don't
oftentimes see a vine that has more than
one punch line that works without it
seeming chaotic and I see a lot of these
days I see a lot of chaotic vines which
is like a lot of screaming and yelling
and then you can just see them trying to
fit in a ton of jokes and it's like you
might want to just take it down and just
stick to one joke sometimes less is more
as cliches that is to say when it seems
to me that I would say that they're
sillier m''d use is that you can be
sillier on vine like some of your videos
which are some of my favorite you just
in with a face you know you just say
something that's just some girl on the
phone and then turn to make a funny face
at the camera and when I see that the
first time I laugh and then I see the
second time I left more than the third
time I left more so it's that repetition
but it's just silly you couldn't just if
you made that if you did a music video
and then turn it made that face on
YouTube I just think people wouldn't
like it you know the way this sucks does
make faces well there's I mean there's
certainly there's like a physical
element like a lot of them I've seen the
more successful ones they have liked it
they're very relatable one joke or kind
of physical thing or and then you're out
but I'm fascinated by I never would have
thought that the looping of it would be
so key that's something that you think
is funny just becomes funny or funnier I
mean the only thing I can relate it to
is the pee and I'm not one of these
people but I observe the people who are
obsessed with a certain comedy movie so
they'll watch it until they've memorized
every part of it and it just gets
funnier to them right I don't even have
the capacity for that but I have the
capacity to watch a six second video 30
times that's right but I'd I would not
have guessed it would keep getting
funnier
it that's just surprising to me right is
that something that you anticipated or
that you learned and now how do you how
do you plan for it like how do you come
up with ideas for me for me everything
is about observational humor if it's
something that I laugh at through the
day for something I chuckle at if
someone does something that annoys me
makes me mad makes me happy I've really
pay attention to observational humor so
that to me is what works because that's
what makes people relate to what you're
doing like the car alarm went yeah the
car alarm
Blayne now on well it's happened often
that I go to my car and I try to open it
or unlock it and I think that alarms off
and it's not and then long goes off and
you immediately feel like a criminal
you know and you know I just I didn't
notice something a lot of people can
relate to and or for instance there's a
vine that I shot you a jump cut that and
all of a sudden you gotta figure out in
your running car exactly so it's like
it's you know observational humor is
just things you notice that people can
relate to that's the very reason why
people comment and tag other people
because they're saying oh this is just
like you or just like me or this is just
like us and that's what you want is
people to relate to what you're doing
so I'm gets a lot more traction NetWare
right now a lot of be like videos too
yeah you know it's funny there's a lot
of meme urban memes like that that are
have been coming out and it's funny to
me because to a lot of people it's new
but in like the urban areas and like you
know we're trying to say you know black
neighborhoods are ghetto neighborhoods
growing up that was just how we talked
you know like when I was in elementary
school and I was with my friends in like
these urban you know schools these
inner-city schools that's just how we
talk like oh man you'd be like this and
like you do something silly to imitate
how they are so that for me goes back to
childhood but recently it's kind of like
a resurgence of like this new meme and
it's funny to watch everyone laugh at it
cuz it's like it's to me it's so old but
yeah the people be like meme it's just
really funny to me because it's just
everyone can get made fun outfits Wow it
you tell us I mean why is does that seem
to be working so well on vine and maybe
a more direct question is it seems like
the perception of the Internet is the
vine is more of a black thing than you
do this I'll just come out I'm just
gonna come out and say it
so you're an authority on this is is
that is that a proper perception I you
know what I'll be
you know honestly maybe I mean maybe it
is I can't say yes I know for sure I
know that with YouTube and all the years
I've been on YouTube the black audience
on YouTube isn't as big or as strong as
some of the other audiences and with
vine for some reason I honestly can't
explain it but I just know that it's
been a lot easier for you know black
people to do comedy on vine and get way
more traction for some reason I honestly
can't explain why that is I don't know
if it's because it's a shorter format I
don't know if it's because socially it's
just really in right now with with the
younger generations if it's more
accessible to you know the young black
audience I don't know but it there does
seem to be something different about
vine that has attracted a lot more of an
urban audience than YouTube ever really
did so and maybe that's why I was able
to do a lot more on vine in the last
year then I was able to do on YouTube in
the last eight years you know so there's
this weird paradox there where I'm like
I don't know what like how did that do
all this on vine so quickly but on
YouTube I mean I had a lot a lot of
great successes on YouTube and I'm
honored to be a part of YouTube and part
of one of you know the veteran crew but
how do I do so much on vine so quickly
but not on YouTube and maybe it's
because that you know now getting back
to that one of your most popular it
might be the most popular one that were
you from you obviously aren't
classically trained or professionally
trained dancer because you can't do that
kind of thing if you're not so he's a
classically pink pirouette Errol is that
what you were doing that's that is a
jazz pirouette okay so surgery jazz pure
awareness
jazz pirouette Estelle I get where are
you from I black I was born in
Louisville Kentucky and raised in
Cincinnati Ohio so I was kind of raised
in the Midwest and my family's all from
Kentucky and Tennessee so a lot of
Southern roots there oh yeah so you know
I think of to about barbecue oh yeah
what was the parental and sibling
situation I'm the youngest of five I'm
baby big-ass baby but yeah the baby and
how much younger is it close together
we're fairly close like my next sibling
I believe is like 37 and I'm 31 okay and
then there's more so 46 years so yeah
that is a legitimate baby yeah in six
years yeah so my my parents were
together and very Christian household
so sometimes nowadays now that I'm older
even though I'm a grown man sometimes
you have those moments we like you want
to do something you like my mom's gonna
see this oh yeah yeah still kind of a
mom like a preacher or something no but
you know we you know I grew up in church
that was the drummer at my church very
involved in church and in my family is
very Christian family so sometimes you
know my mother's very Christian you know
and like I know that she's watching and
she's my biggest supporter so sometimes
when I do things a little bit more on
the adult side or like the edgy side I'm
like mom maybe you don't want to watch
this one she's like I want to watch
everything he do so even I know that
even if it's not something that like you
know she's gonna be crazy about I know
she's still gonna watch and support so
so it sounds like you're not as devout
as your parents are but you know your
mom's watching so it's more your your
maybe a little more accountable to your
mom than you are to God himself
I get that well not you know the thing
is and this that's an interesting point
I think that the differences in
generations it's like I think that when
you speak of devout I think that people
nowadays can be just as devout beige
they just few their activities
differently because I consider myself as
a devout person it's just that I don't
really have any religious habits got it
yeah my faith is still the same I just
don't have I can't say I have any
religious habits you know as some of the
older generations do where they like
they're in church every Sunday Bible
study Wednesday I can have the same
beliefs and spread the same love but I
just may not be having the same
activities that you have so that's an
interesting point so what kind of
household you know you guys joking
around with each other all the time
your parents earn money - I'm very very
grateful cuz my household like my parent
had two great parents that were like
very in love and they were like two
little kids and like they ran they would
chase each other in the house
they would like you know getting to like
W like back then it was WWF now it's w w
yeah yeah they were getting to full-out
WWE like wrestling matches like my mom
would like clothesline my dad and like I
would as a kid I would sit there just
laughing and I was the funniest thing
then I jump in to help my mom and you
know so it was like was he like wearing
like a speedo no that would be really
weird just no that would that's what
they did W said WWF yeah I don't know
but I was wrestling with my dad he's in
a speedo mom could take it to the room
but yeah so and my my family was a very
or is a very fun goofy jokey family my
sister was always trying to you know pop
out and scare people and just you know
mother sister would grab me by my back
pockets and swing me around it was just
you know very fun families so were you
kind of spoiled as the baby now I can't
say I was spoiled um my parents
definitely in any endeavors I wanted to
go on as a child whether it was like
acting or dance or playing instruments I
played the flute I played the clarinet
and then I played the drums anything
within that order
like the first instrument that was a
flute it was it was a clarinet actually
okay yeah I would love to like know what
my dad was thinking the first was it bad
I want to play the clarinet right and
then this was like middle school no this
is elementary Elementor all I wasn't I
was young yeah I was fourth grade okay I
went to school we had a band and I was
just really intrigued by music like an
orchestra yeah and I was really
intrigued by music so I asked my parents
is like can I join the this Orchestra
and they were like well what do you want
to play and I said I won't play the
clarinet and you know and money I'm sure
money was tight back then and it was
expensive but they would always find a
way to make it happen so it was the
clarinet that got me cleaning that when
it was flute the guy him to flute and
when it was drums they eventually got me
the drums so they always supported me no
matter what and so I can't say I was
spoiled spoiled sounds like they just
give you anything but my family
definitely believe who are my parents
definitely lived in hard work and they
definitely enforced that there was no
lazy sitting around not doing things but
when it came to my artistic endeavors
and things I want to do they were always
behind me hundred percent so so was
music was like the first
artistic thing that you kind of latched
on to no I mean dance - yeah dance I
mean I was just an artistic like overall
like I was just an artistic kid and like
they put me in the school put the
Creative and Performing Arts which is a
performing arts school in Cincinnati
Ohio and that started in seventh grade
but before that I was always doing like
you know plays at school and putting on
performances for my parents from my
family and I think that's when they
first noticed because I was doing little
characters and trying to you know mimic
Jim Carrey when he was on in living
color and they were just like you know
he obviously wants to act you know but
in the process of going to the
performing arts school they allowed you
to really immerse yourself and many as
in many different things and many
different things as you wanted to so
that's when the music came in well the
music came in before but I'm saying like
in the process I was able to major in
percussion study drums acting musical
theater I did visual art for a while I
was an art major for a little bit so I
did some sculpting and painting so I was
just really thankful that I was you know
able to be immersed in that and do all
those things because that's where I
needed to be I didn't need to be in like
a full-out
academic school and I think not to get
all preachy but I think parents should
really pay attention to what their kids
are doing and instead of you know trying
to push them like you're gonna be a
lawyer like every man and our family's
been are you're gonna be a doctor like
every man maybe let them feel their way
around and just just support them and
just see what happens because then if I
if they did not probably would be here
with you guys right now so huh so you
went to college as a what did you say I
was a dance and acting major really yeah
okay so that's kind of where you landed
by that point you want you went to
school for dance and acting mm-hmm yeah
I started off I went school and majored
in dance at the time but by the time I
graduated I wasn't sure if I wanted to
be an art major in college
and I was looking into art schools and I
really loved art and I loved studying
art and all the Impressionists the prep
the Impressionists were my favorite and
but I just didn't fill that thump in my
chest about what I was doing I didn't
feel like this is my passion I loved it
but it wasn't like this is what I crave
and what I craved was acting and dance
and at the time I was really really into
dance I loved so loved acting but I was
really into dance so I went to college
primarily at first the dance major
and did that for a while and I loved it
and did that for two years before I got
picked up by a professional dance
company so what kind of dancing we're
talking about here well in college it
mean it was everything it was everything
from ballet to modern to jazz to tap to
African and then it was also hip-hop but
hip-hop which is a part of culture for
me growing up so that was just second
nature I didn't really have to take
classes for hip-hop and then after two
years in college during that a dance
company called Dayton contemporary dance
company or DC DC came and scouted at my
college and they saw me they were like
we want you to audition so and that's
what they that was usual for them they
would come to the college and Scout the
dance dancers and you know bring them in
for auditions and I got it and this is
what you were kind of waiting to happen
it would seem yeah I mean I was looking
to get in to a dance company you know I
wasn't at first but when it came around
and it opened my eyes to it I was like
you know I think I'd like to do this so
I joined the dance company and at that
time also to like financial aid and
school was too expensive for me and my
family and I couldn't I honestly
couldn't continue in college anyway
because I just couldn't afford it so
when that came along it was kind of like
a blessing it's like you know you know
now I can move on to I want to be doing
anyway I don't necessarily need a degree
in dance at the dance you know so or
degree in acting to act so it's fine you
know I won't get to finish college but I
get to do what I love to do so they
picked me up put me in the company and
yeah how did so how do you get from that
to finding fame on YouTube and
discovering that career you did it
blindside you what give us the Obamas
story okay sure that okay you've had to
give many times yeah so after the
dancing I moved to New York during the
dance I moved to New York
and I was doing a little dancing here
and there and the thing that started
happening is that my body started to
kind of give out because when you do
classical stuff like ballet or jazz a
modern it really works really strange
your body and most answers are flexible
and they have free Third Point and all
these other things and I just wasn't I
was really good dancer and I was great
at it but I just wasn't very flexible it
was doing a lot of weird stuff to my
body it was at that time that I realized
you know what like my main first love
really really is acting all that stuff I
was doing as a kid like it's coming full
circle now like I love dance and it was
a passion but my biggest absolute
passion is acting and it
looks less and less painful compared to
what I'm doing right now exactly and so
I started going on auditions and trying
different things and it was around that
time that you two came around so I was
excited I had never owned a camera 2005
2005 and I joined the site in December
18 2005 oh wow
so I got in YouTube and I bought my
first little camera and I was just
recording dumb stuff and posting and you
know back then it was like the Wild West
not everything went and I just really
loved it I mean lot of people weren't
like at work we're seeing like what are
you doing what's the point like what's
and I'm like this is what I do they're
like you do this in your free time and
I'm like yeah but I kept doing it years
ago goes by and whatever not a whole lot
happens what were you doing at the time
on YouTube I was doing a lot of
storytelling actually like I would slog
like vlogging I would just I would just
tell stories like Frances I that total
story once about how I was in college
and I you know met someone in an AOL
chat room and met them in person and
that was a disaster and I'd you know I
would just tell a lot of stories and was
this the Alpha Chi Channel yeah okay and
a lot of people that were slowly
the audience I was slowly picking up
they were demanding like we love your
stories keep telling stories and so I
did that and you know then I would do
like little funny spoofs of like you
know music spoof and I take the song and
just act silly to it or whatever and I
was having a blast and my girlfriend at
that time would come home and like I'd
sure like look what I did and she's like
this is what you're doing all day while
I'm at work so the years go by and I'm
working in a restaurant and that's when
in the fall of 2008 President Obama or
back then I think senator Obama was
running your New York in New York at the
time I'm in New York and he was running
for office and I had an honest even
heard of him all right seen a little bit
and then go walking into work one day
and at that point I was tired I was
tired of like bills and not making
enough waiting tables I've been waiting
tables almost a decade at this point and
so I go into work and this girl was like
oh here comes Obama and everyone kind of
laughed and I laughed about I was a yeah
I think I've seen that guy on TV now she
wasn't white right because she couldn't
have said that she was like she you know
like isn't that racist well no I don't
think so because I don't I don't think
so I was told that in general people of
another race shouldn't tell somebody of
another race that they look like someone
of that race know that that's risky I
mean it can be
I mean I guess oh we all look alike kind
of a thing yeah I think for me
personally I think I've had those
moments where someone tells me like oh
you look like this person and it's like
you know there have the opposite you
know they're different ethnicity and
like they compare me to someone that I
don't look anything alike
but then people have the same ethnicity
compare many people that I don't look
anything alike so I don't I don't
believe in I really really as a black
person and I'm very like vocal about
this I don't believe in being
hypersensitive about issues of color I
don't believe in being color struck you
know I just I just don't and I think we
need to stop that and stop making other
people walk on eggshells because they
just don't know how to approach us you
know I've had so many friends like come
up to me like hey I need to ask you
something I'd never forget it friend
asked me like I want to ask you
something about black people but I don't
want to want to be a friend and they
just simply asked me something about
like I think it's like how sometimes
black guys were stocking caps on their
heads and it was just an honest question
a person was so timid and I like I was
like it's just a question like it's not
even an offensive question whereas I can
understand how someone else probably
would've been so offended but it's like
sometimes people just don't know or
they're just really just genuinely
curious you know it's a question why do
why do black guys wear stocking caps on
their yeah well it's the answer since
I'm sure people like gaff when one okay
girls when they curl their hair as they
use curling lines or they put rollers
why guys when they when they style their
hair they put sometimes they put gel and
they spiked it but I guys when we style
out here we will put we put our hair
will brush it in and we put a stocking
hat which makes it lies flat as you can
see here like I have like to use a
little like like curly wave things like
waves or whatever that's what that's how
we style it-it's just how we style yeah
we put it on until our hair dries or
until it sets then we take it off when
we go out the house so for anyone has
ever been wondering that's why now there
are the guys in the hood that will wear
it just standing around just cuz they
would just want to and that's day that's
cool too but now it's a fashion
statement yeah sometimes if a statement
so yeah but but going back to that
instant you were instance you were not
offended when said here comes Obama you
were like who is Obama yeah I'm just
like who's Hilton who like well my first
thought I got everyone laughs and I kind
of kind of chuckle but then it hit and I
had a the sobering moment of clarity was
like at that time I didn't do any
impressions and I was like if I can come
with an impression of this guy now and
if he wins the presidency he'll be the
first black president which will
automatically probably make him the most
popular guy on the planet if I can come
up with impression now and get out there
first I can kind of like corn to that
market and you're saying this to them
while giving food they're like we just
asked you what the fish special of the
day was no but I was thinking this in my
head and you know so I went home that
night and looked them up and started
looking a lot of different things and
they're like I do look like him I don't
think I don't think I look like him but
I can get the similarity you know we're
tall you know light-skinned he's a lot
slimmer than I am but I I can get this I
get the similarity I don't actually
think we look like and out of the out of
the five years that I've been
impersonating him or doing impressions
of him I never I still have never had
someone stopping so you look know
whatever tell you look like Obama unless
it's someone that knows my videos
already right step for that one girl who
write changed who you're lying so yeah
and so I went home that night and I
didn't do it impressions and I worked on
an impression and made up made a video
and I was really nervous didn't do
impressions and I was like what this is
before the election still before well
this is way before the election and I
was like what am i doing doing and
probably was just nervous to step out
but she's about there but it was like a
defining moment and I did the video and
I put it up and then the audience
response was just really big I was like
I had don't get views like this like
where I've never had used like this and
then where you did you script something
well I did script something and you know
it's funny I just moved about six months
ago into a new apartment and I was
digging through a lot of old box cuz I
had a lot of things in storage that I
finally took out of storage and I'm
digging through boxes and I found the
napkin this long napkin from the
restaurant that I worked at and I wanted
to scribble the whole script to my very
first Obama the whole thing is scribbled
out so I saved it and framed it but I
when I saw that it was like I found some
like great relic yeah yeah but it was
really cool to see it and I'm like man I
actually I I had forgotten that I had
written that written it out so I wrote
it down I had it hanging up and I
remember like glanced at it and you know
but the video well the impression in
that video was way different than it is
now you know but it was a starting point
and people took to it so from there I
just kept working on it and then so what
was the big flash moment what is it what
is the moment call when it
flashes I don't know a flash point the
strobe moment the flash point I mean
that video didn't get 20 million views
no the flash point would have been when
I did my first musical parody cuz that's
the thing is like for some weird reason
and like people don't probably imagine
it I was also even though I've been on
YouTube all the time I was very timid
about putting myself out there and I
would always have ideas that I would sit
on and sit on and sit on and I had
always wanted to do meet more musical
parodies like real musical parodies and
I would never do them but I was think I
would hear a song in my brain is just
structured that way I'd hear songs and
I'd immediately just changed all the
lyrics in my head I'd never do it so I
finally did a parody to a song by ti I'm
called whatever you like but I did it as
Obama and I put that up and that one
just blew up and that was that was the
moment that things that was a flashpoint
cuz but at that time I just moved to
California and I was living in Santa
Barbara and I promised myself I'm not
gonna go back to waiting tables I'm not
gonna do it and that video blew up man I
mean big you know it has 22 million
views maybe yeah something like that and
but it probably got a lot of those in
the few know a lot of it was in the
first few months and the thing was I did
that and I was just I just had an
interview the restaurant I was just
about to go back and I was like
disappointed in myself and then right
when that video popped I started getting
all these offers to do these things like
come here host this makeup really and I
was making more money that I ever ever
had and like in a matter of a month and
within that month I went from almost
going back to waiting tables to now
being self-employed so like singing for
Aretha Franklin yeah yeah that happened
yeah saying for she hired me to come and
perform at her birthday party and the
coolest part was they gave me her guest
list with all these celebrities names
and numbers and had to call them as
Obama and invite them oh wow yes I
didn't like call al Sharpton and it was
like the straightest it was okay so you
got a list and I want to hear this al
Sharpton story well they got a list and
you're like I've got it what you're
getting paid to call these people and
then I can sell the numbers later and
make even more money did you have to
tell them that you were the president
and do you just be like yeah they were
calling they want me to call and stay in
character and
invite people to this party now the only
unfortunate part is that these people
that I was calling I'll have secretaries
and assistants so I would hit a lot of
times hit them first and I didn't get
through to a lot of big people I would
get the assistance that would be
basically cracking up while they're
listening you do this no they would
never this way they never questioned it
they were just like laughing they're
like okay and I'm like you know look it
we have a party here for a wreath of
Franklin and they're expecting you to be
there so I need you to hand over the
word let it let them know to be their
own time and this is an order you know
and it would just like crack up and like
okay I'll let him know you know so that
was fun did you get it talk to you
though uh honestly I don't even remember
that was like that was literally like
five years ago so it was like four years
ago it was a while ago but I get through
to Sharpton I didn't I didn't but it was
a long it was actually a pretty long
list and there was a lot of names I knew
and something I didn't know but it was a
lot of cool people on that list though
before that I mean at what point
obviously you're more than a guy who
does Obama really well I mean do you get
tired of it since November Oh eight you
know yes yes absolutely and that was
that was also like the little dark point
that I had cuz after I did the first
verse that first musical parodius Obama
they blew out and then people challenged
me to go do you think you can do it
again so that the next one I did Beyonce
and it did exactly the same thing again
it was cool but then what happened is I
had this massive audience suddenly just
like - Obama Obama Obama do the voice do
the voice do the voice it was after was
like was a guy that was on would you
talking about Willis
the guy used to say that he passed I
know you're talking about I can't
remember is yeah well that guy you know
and Gary Coleman yeah and he had to
document he was somehow he got fed up
with everyone saying say that say the
line what you talkin about Willis what
you're talking about and I felt like I
was kind of having that moment where
it's like if one more person asked me to
do the voice I'm a loser and I got upset
with my audience cuz when I would try to
post anything else a comedy sketch
musical parody they would get mad they
were like just just stick with Obama
just saying that was beginning to really
hate hearing that just took with Obama
so I hit a point where I just stopped
making videos for like six months
like I just stopped cold turkey
it was probably the worst decision but I
just didn't know back then when was this
this was early this is like early 2009 I
believe like right after everything blew
up I shut it down because I was like it
was great success but it was almost too
much focus on one thing that just drove
me nuts mm-hmm what brought you back
after six months um just missing doing
what I do
missing creating videos for the people
that and have supported me and missing
having a space to express and just be
funny or just be you know fun you know I
missed it and I was just trying to like
find my way back into that and so I
imagine when you brought it back you
were doing the other things but the
Obama thing was still the most
successful did you just come to grips
with the fact that okay I can handle
this now the the weight of the
expectation of doing the voice do Obama
and then what became your strategy to
cope trying to find a balance between
the two and it's it's hard because you
almost kind of have to I hate using this
expression but you gotta have to train
your audience you have to like let them
know hey this is what I'm going to do
and I'm gonna do this for you guys I'm
gonna do the Obama stuff but I'm also
gonna do sketches and I'm gonna do
parody and I'm gonna do musical parody
and so what happens is you get like this
pulling point where the people that are
really that our fans will stick around
and go well I love everything you do how
do you have the people to go like I
don't like the sketches I'm not watching
and you kind of will have a falling away
of people that aren't really true
supporters but you kind of have to go to
that face it gets your core audience
that's gonna stick around that
appreciates whatever you do and you just
keep going from there and then also to
add to make sure I balance it out and
not do too many you Obama videos
back-to-back mmm do it on Bob my video
to a sketch musical parroting Obama
video sketch just like really bounce it
out what was it a lingering struggle for
you to still not have the other videos
be received as well consistently as the
Obama thing that you would take it
personally you know I know we take
things personally all the time when
people don't respond the way we want
them to so I mean is that a part of the
challenge for you or at least over the
past few
and maybe vine has kind of changed that
for you hmm
as that brought you out of something
that was kind of a few years of struggle
identity struggle um I mean yeah kinda
it's just I'm trying how to answer that
written properly vine has kind of
brought me at it because it has been a
lingering problem where it's like you
know I I don't know it's just it's it's
a mix of a lot of things having been on
YouTube for so long you get sometimes
you get creatively winded you know and
then also dealing with the struggle of
my own personal audience and the Obama
thing and then the sketches like
sometimes it is a struggle to get people
to appreciate things outside of Obama
but I have to also have to realize it's
Obama so nothing that I do is I mean
anything that I do is gonna be still
it's still gonna be kind of hard to
compare that because it's it's an
impression that now is like known
worldwide and a lot of people know it so
it's like it's gonna be kind of hard to
top that with normal quote/unquote
normal stuff so I don't really expect
for my other videos to do as well as the
Obama videos you know and I'm okay with
that as long as they do well in general
so what does that mean you know moving
forward obviously he's always gonna be a
public figure he was a two-term
president but you know two years from
now he won't be the president anymore
right and as you think about you know
you're an entertainer now and I assume
that's what you want to keep being right
now have you thought about the landscape
years from now or it's okay he's a
public figure but obviously that's not
um you can't keep tapping into that in
the same way that you can now why he's
an active president right and and that's
like the other piece of the puzzle is
like to start segue into film and
television which is which was ultimately
the entire time my goal and just last
year I was actually shot two films one
here in the States and one in India and
that for me just really brought me alive
like just to be able to do something
that was not only outside of Obama but I
was like outside of mmm
YouTube and the internet and the web to
do these things makes me really excited
so as I continue to do this and even
though he has some years left in office
the goal in the next phase of things now
is to like continue doing videos but at
the same time start
branching out because I'm not gonna sit
back and just go Obama heavy and do all
on stuffing in the moment he leaves
office I'm just sitting around because
that that tends to be like the number
one question from fans so but what are
you going to do when he's out of office
as if I've never thought of it so it's
like I'm going to like I'm not like that
part is always like already in process
like you know auditioning and doing more
traditional media things and also too
right now particularly I'm in a phase
now I'm kind of restructuring my brain
to think more sketch minded because I
love sketches but I don't I haven't
written a lot of sketches in the past
and recently I've been taking a lot of
time to sit and write sketches and and
and and and try to get my brain into
that route so that as things start to
taper off with Obama I'm still I still
have a lot of other things that I have
going on besides just that no well we
saw the along the roadside trailer and
you know it seems like there's a lot of
promise there yeah I mean it's it's
doing really well in the film festival
circuit it's one better you're the lead
in that I am the lead yeah and it won
Best Picture like four or five times
really yeah awesome
it's won a lot of other accolades and
what's cool about that is like not only
am I to lead in that but and this was an
Oscar yeah I like saying yes some of the
festivals yeah a lot of the film
festivals and what's cool about not only
being the lead in that but also that one
of my supporting actors is Michael
Madsen who's like a legend he's an you
know Reservoir Dogs like hugged him one
time and scary dude yeah magical imagine
working with him he's an intent he's a
very intense guy but um you know it's
cool that like for me that was huge to
be a lead in a film and then someone
like Michael Madsen and some other stars
wearing it as well so that was a big
moment for me and then I flew to India
to be in another movie with that one I'm
not allowed to like legally talk about
because then you know in DA's and we
don't care we what we won't prosecute
you but you know when to in dearly this
summer and shot that and I'm actually
going back to India next week to when
will we find out about that that's a
good question I don't know but and it's
a big it's a big franchise in India it's
like you know like remember the the
comedy movie scary moving by the Wayans
for like the first two were like a big
deal yeah it's like that kind of thing
out in
India so like I'm literally about to be
like all over billboards and stuff in
India and it's it was a really cool
experience I'm going back in a week
because they have to reshoot scenes so
it's like hey we have to reshoot scenes
so you have to come back to India oh my
oh okay that's a that's a great free
trip so if that works out it seems like
it is beginning to work out is it the
kind of thing that it's like okay I'm
gonna be an actor now you know YouTube
fine is that just okay that's kind of
like this thing I did at some point or
is it like no no I'm gonna keep pushing
it on all fronts no I'm gonna keep
pushing it on all fronts I probably
won't be if things go as I would like
for them to in the you know film and
television circuit I won't be as heavy
into YouTube and vine but I would never
want to completely abandon it cuz it's
like there's so many people there that
love me and have supported me and I
would never want to walk out on that but
we see I mean what we see complaints eat
on amongst your vine followers that
you're not giving him enough I know
because it's like I went from posting
twice a day to posting every day to like
I took there was a point recently where
I'd like just stop for like a month like
a whole month and the reason why is
because after doing so much once again
you sometimes hit points where you're
like you get creatively winded and I was
I felt like I was forcing ideas and I'd
rather stop and take a break and also
just live my life cuz we all have lives
to live I'd rather do that than to keep
forcing ideas and and giving them crap
I'd rather stop doing that and just wait
until I'm fresh again and then come back
which I'm beginning to do now which do
you see is more strategic vine or
YouTube moving forward for you honestly
probably YouTube really I have this
weird thing now I'm trying to get
integrated back in because I miss I miss
YouTube a lot you know and I'm not gonna
stop buying I'm not gonna stop YouTube
but I've been I've been way more quiet
on YouTube than I ever have been on vine
you know vinyl be okay I'm gonna keep
posting bye and that's easy to do but
vine was kind of like a weird therapy
for me because like I took some time off
from YouTube and when I was doing buying
it it kind of gave me a new method to
come up with ideas that I can turn into
not only vines but I could take those
same ideas and turn them into sketches
too okay so so you're fans should expect
more YouTube videos YouTube videos and
movies yeah okay yeah yeah got it now
the one thing we have
talk about yet is your other strategy
for success which is dating other
YouTube yeah you have one of the first
that I can remember first like laughing
first public relationships you know
public YouTube relationships going back
to miss lisa lavie yeah we're gonna go
there we're gonna talk about that okay I
wish you could see his face right now
when we met you okay so so she was
amazing singer on YouTube first and then
was like touring singer anyway and
otherwise it was was a YouTube first for
her I don't I don't know did you launch
a career no I did not launch a career
it was just YouTube but you guys dated
for a long time I mean how many years
are we talking like four years four
years and you had it I think one of the
things makes it interesting because you
had a collaborative channel yes you had
a collaborative channel so it was it you
know I remember thinking okay yeah
so this is because you know so many
firsts mm-hmm yeah you know we get to
see and experience so many first because
of YouTube but I can't think of another
how did that just tell us about that way
I know it's I know it's over now I know
you don't have the channel or the
relationship now okay so what's the
what's the 2014 version of that story
what do you mean what retrospect yeah I
mean is really not a whole lot to say on
it I mean it's just you know that was a
very public relationship and you know
like some relationships just ran its
Coronets course and you know that's
pretty much it in a nutshell you know
like well did would you having made that
relationship public mm-hm
would you say that is something that I
will not do again or oh no that wasn't
really that wasn't the problem honestly
I don't know I mean I now when it comes
to like dating life I tend to be way
more private just because of like you
know that was from that breakup for me
was the first time experiencing
something that public or particularly a
breakup that public what was there a
breakup vlog there was no breakup vlog
no you didn't break up with her via
then channel you shared no no no no no
we didn't have a brain oh no no that was
they just started the video just the
other videos just stopped
we had actually stopped daily vlogging
long before we broke up
we're not long before but our daily
vlogs to get ahead stopped a while
before because we both had just gotten
kind of like exhausted with having to
edit videos every day I was busy she was
busy then we also had this collaborative
channel which took a lot of time and we
both kind of got winded with the vlog so
we didn't break up via vlog now yeah
what would we say I probably would have
gotten a lot of views I'm just saying
yeah yeah but yeah I mean yeah that's
pretty much the story I don't know if I
answered your question so what's your
love life like now well yeah I mean
there was andreaschoice
youtuber you guys had a you guys were
dating - right no we're good that one
from I was told that's an internet rumor
no we've never dated and she's a good
friend of mine but no really that's
funny that's a rumor that's what I was
yeah that's what I was alluding to I was
like you have this strategy that's
totally messing with you I don't believe
you have some subversive dating strategy
no no no that's funny though that's news
to me
what we don't try to turn your biscuits
into like a gossip so I'm sorry that but
these are the things that people want to
know so we have to ask them but the but
the whole choice to you know create the
shared relationship channel mmm it
sounds like maybe that's you're gonna go
a little bit more private well yeah it's
just I I think that and then people like
us make up stuff like oh he's dated so
they're not just friends
ya know um yeah it's it's to be private
I'm already a very private person as it
is and people look at that [ __ ] well
how are you private you vlog you're
youtuber your whole life is public and
it's like yeah I said but you also see
what I show you you don't see what I
don't want you to see you know I I
control that the moment I hit crop or a
delete or you know I cut something out
of an edit or I'm sorry out of a blog
yeah so with dating it's like I think
it's fun it's not naturally when you're
in a relationship you want to share your
life with the person you know you might
Instagram with them or put them you know
you see them in a video but I don't know
how public I would be in the future
about relationship
I think finding someone who who maybe
doesn't even necessarily enjoy being on
video would be cool cuz it's like okay
we can have our own private life our own
private space without having every
YouTube comment or Viner
you know look into our lives and make
assumptions or you know whatever else so
I think a little privacy might be in
order
well listen i think that uh i don't
think you held back is there anything
else you wanted I don't think you guys
held back I think I think we should
that's how we should in there biscuits
now is there anything else you want to
tell I think the implication here is
that you should start a collaborative
relationship based vine channel so it's
like maybe six seconds at a time me and
you are gonna change the world
that's the shortest relationship ever
you could call it a new vine you call it
six second man and no that would not be
good no I call it six seconds in heaven
alright I'm had to do that with my wife
so far I've kept her completely off the
internet we're gonna start a behind Wow
damn and in a specific type all right
it's time to sign the table of dimmed
lighting Wow you go a black pen that's
racist
[Music]
and there it is our ear biscuit with
Iman Crosson you should tweet at him let
him know what you thought that's
twitter.com slash alphaCAT also follow
me on vine if you're into that his
username there is also alpha cat 2.4
million followers over there it's
amazing how you know he just capitalized
he saw the pattern of how it was kind of
the next YouTube got involved with the
right group of people who were asserting
themselves and just blew up I mean I
certainly respect him for capitalizing
on that well and he's making money six
seconds at a time
not bad there's a pressure you know we
talked about this pressure of in doing
what we do of always signing up for the
next new thing oh this new thing called
Twitter just happened
I better get that username we better
grab rhett and Link and I'll grab link
Lamont you can grab Rhett MC on that and
this new thing called vine we can do
that tool that was that was 2008 I know
that we did that but yeah but that's the
last time I really felt the pressure of
it and actually went into it you know I
fell into the hole I got to chase this
thing and because it might be the next
big thing by the time vine has happened
I might forget it should we do it is it
too late well it's certainly not too
late should we do it
well I will say that I'm gonna go
directly after this I'm gonna delete my
videos from vine because I do have a
vine account with I think like 10,000
followers or something I don't know
anything okay because I started it a
while back and then I said you know I'm
joining vine just FYI tweeted it out and
people came over there I had three
videos that were not vine videos they
were just six second videos because I
kind of knew that people were doing
these like jump cut things but I didn't
I didn't never appreciate the humor and
I did not see I wasn't thinking about
investing in it right and like actually
making a thing of it
so I looked at the three videos ahead up
there recently and I just in preparation
for this conversation with him
you're gonna delete him but what are
they uh they are the very first one I
ever did was me coming into the office
and it like I like piece together like
me in the car then me opening the door
and then like saying hello to different
people in the office but it was like no
comedy no it was just kind of mistimed
and it wasn't supposed to be funny and
then I did one where I woke up and said
something and then I did one where like
I'm vlog like a six second I just woke
up
yeah something right after gorgon went
viral the shift is shifted commercial
and he we went over there to his office
he was getting all the calls I just
filmed him answering a call and he just
said what type of car is it which is
kind of funny but you know it just
didn't I didn't understand the mechanics
of it so it just says no pun intended
yeah don't delete the gorgon one no I'm
going to support point in time it but I
don't want to send people over there too
and first of all I think if we're gonna
do this we got to do it as a rhett and
Link fine you know we don't need to do
this thing where I've got one and you
got one and I started a couple months
later you start it and then neither one
of us really puts anything up there I'm
not saying we're gonna do it but if
we're going to do it it's gonna be on a
Rhett link if you want to follow us just
do it on Twitter read MC link Lamont and
the rhettandlink man six seconds we
could have made we could have made like
30 vines just in the time that we've
been talking since well it's not that
easy I think you've just proven there's
not that easy you the three things that
you did you now deleting yeah what but
now I feel like I talked to an expert I
talked to an expert I'm inspired I know
I'm not gonna do it though you know
let's just get realistic here let me be
clear I want I'm not going to start a
vine because it wouldn't be prudent
I was a mixing of let's approve it thing
is it all right guys next week no other
year [ __ ] its Bush that's a bush
thing yeah first senior next week next
air biscuit thanks for listening period
[Music]
[Music]